okay morning thanks for coming thank the
organizers the for a very interesting
Burke shop unfortunately I have to leave
shortly after my talk to the airport Tom
told me earlier this week that the term
explicit is better than the term
deterministic it's like what we're doing
so the topic is an explicit reckless
code for BSC this is joint work with
Benny Appelbaum and villain dahveed
they're both from my department the
owners a student we're considering the
case where you have an encoder and in a
decoder they are speaking over a binary
symmetric channel where p is any number
between zero and one half we don't have
any assumptions of about P being bounded
away from one half but it will require
that p is constant the situation is the
situation in which the encoder does not
know the crossover probability P so what
can I do for messages of length K what
the encoder has to do it has to generate
an infinite sequence in our case these
are bits and the decoder will receive
these noisy bits and will try to decode
we use a definition of the following
definition of achieving capacity uh we
want for every p and for every constant
gap to capacity if you have the right
length means that the difference between
the capacity of the channel and the rate
of the code is delta then are the
probability over the channel and only
the channel because everything here is
deterministic that the decoder will find
y tends to 0 doesn't find y sorry tends
to 0 as k tends to infinity so this is
news for achieving capacity previous
work which is related to rapist codes so
of course the topic was introduced by
Mike and he suggested these alt codes
for the erasure channel and was later
improved in the running time by Amin
charcoal I for the Gaussian channel
there's the work of uma air is taught in
a bowl nail and for the BSC channel
there's a work from a bunch of fellows
from MIT I don't remember all the names
vary but a Krishnan shower room apart on
each side now all these constructions
are characterized by the fact that they
are probabilistic what do I mean by that
I mean that they build an ensample of
codes and they show that if you pick a
code randomly from it then you get nice
properties that would mean that when I
look here at the probability the
probability depends not only on the
channel but also on the choice of the
code from the ensamble ok we're
interested in one specific code why well
because from a theoretical point of view
if the encoder and decoder have to pick
a code from the ensamble that means that
they have to share some randomness that
means that there is some error free side
channel and from theoretical point of
view we wanted to avoid that assumption
three other features of our construction
first of all it's systematic and that
the first K bits are simply the bits of
X the construction is computationally
efficient asymptotically what it means
is that it's roughly constant time per
bit of the code and you can do all the
computations in parallel with
logarithmic depth circuits means that in
theory you could get high throughput the
decoding error probability so how fast
does this error
10 20 it tends almost exponentially fast
that we have here a function which tends
to infinity but it could be arbitrarily
slow so it's almost exponential and if
you fix k and you'll forget about
capacity you just want to reach a very
low error then as n tends to infinity
the decoding error decreases in this
fashion jeans okay now the first method
that we use is concatenated codes I was
talking to honey what about this and he
said yes of course concatenated codes
are the remedy for all your problems in
life so let me just say one word what
concatenated codes are for the sake of
the people who are not confident with
this definition and then i'll tell you
why we love them so what you doing a
concatenated code you have two codes you
have an outer code in an inner code you
take your information x and then you
apply your outer code you're going to a
longer word why why of out and then you
take this longer bird you divided into
sub blocks and you apply in parallel to
each of the sub locks in inner code and
then you get your final code word so the
rate is the product of the rates of the
codes and the reason that we love
concatenated codes is that if these
blocks are short let's say that they are
logarithmic length then we have no
problem to apply say even maximum
likelihood decoding because we can
afford exponential in log n time that
would be polynomial okay so that's one
feature that we like another feature
that we like is that from the point of
view of the outer coat
the channel is much better than the
original channel so you get this
amplification of a decoding success and
the third property that we like that we
don't use in our construction but is
often used instead of having to pick a
code randomly from an ensample what you
could do is you could use all the code
words all the codes from the in samba
they knowing that most of the codes and
the in-sample are great and then you
don't have an ensample anymore then it
becomes so these are the benefits of the
concatenated codes I don't want to
elaborate a lot on the outer code that
we use let me just say a few words about
it the outer code that we use is a code
by Goswami and indique it has a rate
which tends to 1 the the rate depends
there on the size of the alphabet and
it's a really great code it's almost
linear time decodable and encode herbal
and the it's in like almost MDS type of
code because the number of errors that
it can tolerate is linear in the
redundancy so if you add orbits the
difference between in MKS are then they
can handle some constant fraction of our
in the number of errors so it's a really
useful code for our purposes so let me
just focus on the inner code so what I
want to show is the outer coat rayless
it's not a fixed outer coat yeah so why
not just use an MDS code because then
you won't get linear time decoding and
encoding
okay so what do we need from our inner
code what we're looking for so now I'm
focusing on the inner code and I'm not
gonna evaporate any more on the outer
code or on the concatenation this is
kind of stand out so what we need is we
want to construct generating matrix it
will start with the identity matrix this
will be the first k rose and then we
want to generate the next row and the
one after that and continue in this
fashion in infinite sequence this will
be our generating matrix so it has K
columns and the goal is after you have
computed the first n minus 1 rows how do
you compute the next row this is a the
problem it's one fixed matrix that we
were interested in given K V and so of
course the encoding is simply
multiplication by the you take the
matrix and you x the information word
decoding is simply maximum likelihood
decoding namely you given your giving
you a noisy code word and you look for
the closest code word in your code and
let's focus now on how to compute this
fellow how to compute the next row and
so so guy is your k really log in there
where you think about it okay no k tends
to infinity utah yes yes yes yes yes
this will be actually let's say that
this is k sometimes it's this better use
the following notation i'll call i'll
call this k in and here i'll use log of
k sorry so this is the length of the
information word and the inner code will
have block lengths which are logarithmic
in d here you can afford
running exponential time yep that's
exactly ok so we a plan to use maximum
likelihood decoding so what I need to
tell you is a sufficient condition for
maximum likelihood to succeed and then
what we want to do is we want to build a
code generating matrix which satisfies
the sufficient condition ok so everybody
knows that random codes are our good
code but the property of random codes
can be focused at and can explain why
maximum likelihood decoding is
successful so the sufficient condition
it's also necessary but are only
concerned here with the sufficient
condition for ml success
a sufficient condition is that you have
what is called an average spectrum okay
what this condition says is that you
look at the weight distribution of a
random code so suppose I were to pick
the rows of this matrix at random
uniformly at random and independently
then I would get this random code and I
could ask how many code words do I have
of weight I let's denote this by W star
I n this is the expected number
expected number of code words wait
I actually I'm not gonna be looking at
the code words I'm going to look at the
information words which are map to code
words of wait I it's the same thing
you'll see later why I'm interested in
the information words in on day ok now
it's easy to see that this number is 2
to the K minus 1 times n choose I times
2 to the N just to be concrete there's
easy it's easy to calculate for I
greater than 0 of course and now there's
a theorem arm I am quite sure that this
theorem is for everybody who's an expert
in the field knows about it it took it
took us some time to find the reference
for it the reference we could find is a
theorem bipod d live before i believe
and what the theorem says that if you
take any linear code and you look at the
weight distribution of this linear code
and if wi n is very close to W star I
and in the following sense so first they
want the minimum distance to be the
right minimum distance so you want this
to be 0 if I is less than this Delta of
Gilbert or shop of times n this is our
this is a parameter which depends on the
rate of the code and here you have to to
the little o of n times W star I n
otherwise for the higher eyes ok so what
petilla of tells us is that if you take
up a linear code whose weight
distribution satisfies two properties
first of all you have a minimum distance
which is what you expect to get in a
random code and secondly the weights the
number of code words you haven't of each
way is similar to the
that you have in a random code then
maximum likelihood decoding is
successful ok w star and supposed to be
provided by I'm counting I'm not asking
what is a proportion of the fellows a
mistake minus 2 to the N
good thanks yeah okay strange okay good
so party lab gives us this condition
which we would like to make it it
actually tells us that that the even
more specific that the probability of
decoding failure of ml decoding failure
this probability will be bounded by the
probability over the random code ml
decoding the star for the random code x
2 to the little o of n and since this
decreases exponentially this fellow is
not very interesting okay good so now
what we want to do is we want to mimic
we want to mimic this theory we can't
use it as is we're not able to find the
code which has such a large minimum
distance so what we're going to do is
we're going to devise an exponential
time algorithm that is given the first n
minus rose n minus 1 rose and computes
the next row the rn's row and what it
will satisfy it will have win7 will be 0
if I is less than some in over log in I
could be more specific here but I don't
want to love you and here it will be W
star I n i'm still a little o of n if i
is greater than this threshold and we
also add here some polynomial so this is
a the code I will but the weight
distribution of the code I plan to
construct and what we do is we extend
the proof of multilayers theorem to show
that under this weight distribution the
probability of decoding failure is
bounded by 2 to the minus 80 so what
makes the what influences here the
exponent is the minimum distance ok no
big surprise good so now let me tell you
how we construct such a code
if you have a code which satisfies this
weight distribution ml decoding will be
good enough for us okay so
let's look at let's look at how this
thing evolves this is a random process
and let's see how this thing involves so
if i have w star of I n minus 1 and W
star of I plus 1 n minus 1 and now I'm
adding another row randomly what happens
to these two quantities well half the
fellows are going to stay with the same
weight because they are orthogonal to
the row you add and half the fellows
will not be orthogonal to the road you
add and therefore their weight will
increase and here again one half will
stay with the same weight and one half
will have an additional one in their way
okay so what you could see is that you
have this recurrence which tells you the
W star I n equals one-half of W star i
minus 1 n minus 1 plus W star I and n
minus 1 this if we're able to mimic this
recurrence then we will be able to
achieve this part ok good so um how do
we do that ah so here what we do is we
construct it's easier to look at it as a
game of balls and bins
so a ball a ball is an information word
and it falls into a bin which is indexed
by the weight of the code word that
correspond to that information word okay
so you have your bins and you have here
the number of balls in each bin good so
if I have here some weight I the height
of this thing will be my WI let's say n
minus 1 now I want to add another row
what do I do so i'm looking for a row
that will kind of split this thing into
half half of it will increase its weight
and the other half will remain in the
same place this is what i'm trying to do
okay so
suppose I fix a vector X and I pick our
this is my role that I'm want to add
uniformly at random from this as a k
vector a que bit vector and I look at
the random variable which is let's call
it sin of X which is simply the product
of our RX then I know that this random
variable is a one-half Bernoulli random
variable so and this is what we saw over
here right that it goes won't have to
hear one hefty so this is good but what
you should notice is that these random
variables over the different exes are
not independent because of linear
dependencies they not bein so well we
can't apply our channel if bound or
anything of that sort on the other hand
if you look at these random variables
EDX and they are pairwise independent so
since they are pairwise independent
because if you have two x's which are
different responding random variables Z
X and then x2 will be independent so if
they're pairwise independent then you
can apply chebyshev's inequality okay
what does chebyshev inequality give us a
tin in this in this situation it tells
us that if I have some arbitrary set W
of code words of information worth sorry
this w is a subset that which is a
subset of 0 1 to the K and if I tell you
that this w is not too small let's say
at least two times n squared then what I
can show using chebyshev's inequality is
that 1 minus 1 over 2n fraction of the
arse are good in the in the sense that
they take W and kind of split it into
132 third parts
ok so I'm this is my situation I have
here my W and I say that I split it into
one-third two-third if this part is aa
between one-third and two-thirds of W
and so is this part ok I'm not I'm not
dividing it exactly by half it's a
physis two divided it 14 two thirds ago
occupancy models listicle approach to
try polarization or some other sort of
transform that will allow you to treat
the occupant ceases independent random
variables and then come back through a
inverse transform ya these are
techniques to to approximate the
binomial binomial a they have other
applications a job basically
posterization would allow you to treat
the random variables is independent
because you only have a constraint on
the total occupancy I think that that
would work with probability namely I was
all I would always have these leftovers
which I could not get rid of this is
what I suspect them ization and inverse
personalization its exact if you don't
have to check I have to check that ok
can you use it he's getting T terminus
together yeah the hope ok so so the
problem i have here so let's see what do
i get i get here that i can
simultaneously one-third two-third split
all the bins which are sufficiently
large because such a huge fraction of
the fellows are good so by Union bound
at least one-half be ours are good ok
what about the small fellows right so
this is the part where are we have to do
some kind of for tweaking so what we do
is we mark balls ok so M will be the set
of marked balls
whenever an information word a ball
belongs to a pin which is small the
small meaning that its size is less than
this threshold we mark it and then it
remains marked forever okay so you have
here the balls and you also have these
marked balls which are spread may be
here there are some mark balls I don't
care that now they're in a big bin
they're still marked okay and now when
I'm looking at the size of a bean I'm
looking only at the unmarked balls in
the bin and I apply this method so I
only have this problem with the market
balls so what I do is I take the
leftmost bin which has a marked ball and
I look for a an R which splits this left
mode leftmost bin and since this bin can
maybe contain one two three four very
few code words very few balls all I all
I can guarantee is that I will be able
to move 18 of them some for constant
fraction of them to the right good so
now what it means is that every log n
steps Oh of log n steps I'm able to move
the leftmost black a bin one position to
the right so after n steps the leftmost
black bin will be at most will have a
weight at least in over log in so these
are the unmarked balls i'm very happy
with them but about the marked balls the
mark balls every log in steps i was able
to ship them by one position so again
after n over if after n steps the marked
above which is most the most left will
also be in position at least n over log
in so i get my oh so I get my minimum
distance guarantee what about the weight
distribution for the fellows with of
higher I well these are the Mars bars in
each step I'm are
a polynomial number of balls C times n
squared times n and I have at most n
steps so this is polynomial in N and
here the error that I get instead of
doing one-third two-thirds instead of
doing that I doing something smaller
accumulates instead of doing one half
accumulates to this fellow and that's
how I you are guaranteed my bounds okay
good let me finish with fair to open
problems
first I open the first open problem I
want to describe is our construction
requires the decoder to listen to the
beginning of the conversation what
happens if we have a situation in which
the decoder starts listening in the
middle of the transmission that would
mean that are what the decoder is doing
is he's not looking at the initial part
of the matrix is only listening to
what's happening at some contiguous part
of the philly trees how can i construct
a matrix such that every contiguous n
rows induces a weight distribution which
is a sword that we need we don't know
how to do that some lower bound I don't
know so but even if it's not possible to
achieve capacity what is it what's
possible no of course it won't be
systematic right that's it you bet you
can't have both and that's what you
started yep this was our initial
initialization yeah ok so that's the
first problem the second open problem
which are more in progress than open is
how to extend this construction to other
binary memoryless symmetric channels
the idea here is to employ the external
properties of the binary erasure channel
and the binary symmetric channel with
respect to these concatenated codes so
it seems that the worst you could do to
this code is for the inner code to
introduce a binary symmetric channel
given that the capacity is fixed and the
worst that you could do for the outer
code is to erase symbols so it seems
that from an external extremal point of
view it is possible to prove that this
construction works for any BMS a channel
so DSC works when general there's no I'm
not familiar of such a theorem but our
errands has a glowing with you you get
an extra factor of n in the airport
videos on it which is nothing in our
terms ok who's the process ok that he's
here loser ah ok thanks for everyone
you should get hold of him out okay so
you speak the speech